Marvel has officially begun spinning its
latest web snaps a black widow actress
Scarlett Johansson on the set of the
upcoming superhero standalone hit the
Internet on Wednesday confirming that
production is now underway and Saban
Norway the photographs themselves some
shared by Norwegian news outlet dog lit
up and others uploaded by NRK feature
Johansson doing normal actor type things
while filming a movie and aren't all
that interesting if we're being totally
candid here she's seen filming scenes
where Natasha Romanov does relatively
unremarkable stuff she pops into a local
convenience store puts bags in a car and
takes a ferry to an unknown destination
no one else that Marvel fans would
recognize can be spotted on the set so
it seems that Black Widow director Kate
Shortland may be getting some of
Johansson solo scenes completed first
something that is of note however is
Johansson's hair color in the pictures
she sports Natasha's signature red
tresses which offers a clue as to when
the Black Widow movie takes place
the only time Black Widow didn't have
completely red hair in the MCU was when
she rocked a blonde Bob and Avengers
infinity war and when she sported a half
blonde half ginger hairdo after the
five-year time jump in Avengers endgame
given that Black Widow sacrificed
herself in Avengers endgame throwing
herself off the cliff of war mere so the
Hawkeye could retrieve the soul stone
and help complete the Avengers time
heist mission the only option for the
Black Widow films time setting is the
past her hair color in these set photos
backs up that notion it also seems to
cooperate previous reports claiming that
Black Widow is a prequel film set in two
different time periods one that follows
Natasha during her time spent working as
a state secret agent for the KGB and
another that picks up 15 years after the
dissolution of the Soviet Union which
happened in 1991 this would mean that
Black Widow would partially take place
during Natasha's teenage years then
documenter trials and triumphs in the
year 2006 as she forms her own identity
and finds her way in the u.s. since--
Johansson's Black Widow didn't debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe until 2010
first appearing in the Iron Man sequel
there's plenty of time to range over and
gaps in the heroes on-screen story to
film on the flip side some expect
that perhaps the solo movie is set in
the more recent past the five years
between Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame geeks worldwide writer
Thomas Pulido theorized on Twitter that
the upcoming film could see Black Widow
training her replacement referring to a
different secret agent character from
the comics who first appeared in the
late 90s theory the film takes place
between infinity war and endgame and
features nat training a new black widow
Yelena Bulova perhaps who will factor
into future movies flashbacks the Nats
past will be sprinkled throughout the
film as well it's not hard to see how
this theory could work
Avengers endgame showed audiences that
while the other Avengers went on their
own journeys after the snap Black Widow
was trying to keep things together and
continue protecting the world in the
event of another massive threat she
organized meetings with others still
active heroes and even track down
Hawkeye to bring him home it wouldn't be
the craziest thing to think that Natasha
used a few years after the snap and
before the time heist to Train another
heroine to take her place should
something happen to her
conjecture aside there's one thing about
Black Widow of which we are certain
Johansson will reportedly share the
screen with a shining group of stars
fighting with my family and midsummer
actress Florence Pugh The Handmaid's
Tale actor ot [ __ ] Ben lay stranger
things and Hellboy actor David Harbor
and Academy Award winner Rachel vice are
all said to have joined the cast of
Black Widow or have otherwise been in
talks to do so according to a March 2019
article from The Hollywood Reporter
Hughes character has arguably the
biggest part to play she's described as
quote a spy on the same level as Black
Widow likely her moral opposite will be
used character be a new Black Widow and
training will she be her number one
competition within the KGB could she be
both no matter what the story turns out
to be we're excited to find out check
out one of our newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]